the stage is set for The Showdown in
Milwaukee we are just hours away from
the first GOP Presidential debate
tonight at 9 pm Eastern right here on
Fox News Eight Republican candidates
getting their first big shot to convince
you the American voter that they have
what it takes to be the GOP nominee the
candidates itching to get things started
watch here
I'm the only one whose sole purpose is
running to be the 47th president of the
United States the way I'm preparing is
by talking to voters that's actually
what I think matters more than getting
prepped memos from Super pac-paid
political Consultants with pre-prepped
robotic attack lines against my
opponents no we've got a country to save
that's why we have to have a new
generational leader I've been preparing
for this first Republican presidential
debate my whole life how about if we put
the person with the best character
it is the next president the last thing
I want to talk about or think about is
the president of candidate with his
shirt off this is really my first
opportunity on a broad scale to
introduce myself to American hey I'm
going to be the only one on that stage
that grew up uh you know working on a
farm working on a ranch
the Republican contenders are handling
debate prep in less ways unusual ways
too Vivek Rama Swami posting a video of
himself going shirtless to play some
tennis and claiming it's all part of his
unique preparation but that doesn't hold
a candle to what happened to Doug burgum
just this morning right before Newsroom
we got word in our ear that the governor
had hurt injured himself playing
basketball you can see him here limping
in crutches after tearing his Achilles
tendon during a pickup basketball game
that unfortunately for him went horribly
wrong burgum was rushed to local ER in
Milwaukee he has been discharged from
the hospital he says he will debate but
will he be able to stand
North Dakota there's a phrase called
Cowboy Up so many Americans make so many
sacrifices think of law enforcement
think of military what they do for all
of us I mean
if you're going to leave this country
you ought to be able to stand on one leg
for two hours Pain's not Pain's not a
factor at this point
all right here we are the only pain that
we feel here in Milwaukee is Harold
tonight it's really hot guys it is seven
degrees hotter here than Miami and
Harold let me give you the first crack
at it before you melt
well tonight's gonna be a good night uh
Dana I would Echo everything you've said
this is I think debates and discourse
are important for the country they're
important for the democracy and
obviously tonight for the Republican
party uh I think voters are going to be
looking for a few things who who has
that common touch who's able to talk
about issues in a way uh that that
doesn't belittle or for that matter to
mean others to who's able to talk with
some specificity around some of the
substance the economy War and Peace
National Security which I include the
border is a part of schools and crime I
hope to hear all of them talk about
those things and you better believe that
Brett and Martha are going to ask some
some tough questions as they should
about how and how not only they would
lead the country but how might they work
together with both parties in the house
and the Senate but this is the first
step the first night and uh I got to
tell you I'm looking forward to it I'm
really looking forward to the sun
shifting
Jesse you'd be able to push him over
with one one finger what are you looking
for tonight Jesse I think we want to see
someone with common sense Solutions a
Clear Vision someone who's comfortable
in their own skin maybe wit maybe charm
relaxed aggression
but Ron DeSantis is under a ton of
pressure he's lost momentum he's lost a
lot of money he's reshuffled his
campaign and it's going to be a big pile
on so donors and his supporters are
probably looking to see whether this guy
can make it and we don't know if he's
going to be able to make it or not he
can't look annoyed when they do the
split screen and he has to show that if
anything happens to Trump he has to be
the one to consolidate the base and be
there Vivek is on the rise DeSantis is
probably going to take a few shots at
him the guys on TV more than kill Mead
he's bright he's got a sunny optimistic
message that is connecting with people
he could fizzle out next month or he
could gain a lot of traction the jury's
still out he's never really been
attacked on his record but he'll be
attacked tonight Christy you're going to
see a lot of Chris Christie whether you
like it or not he's trying to tangle
with anybody on the stage he's going to
insult Donald Trump and he's going to
probably collide with anything that gets
in his way and fight for attention now
Scott is the Mr Nice Guy he's done
nothing so far he needs a breakout
moment Nikki also needs a breakout
moment she needs something to get a
little more attraction and the guy that
broke his leg I've never heard of him
before and uh Isa Hutchinson you say
every time we talk about him though
I've never talked about him before
all right judge your name one thing that
was pretty surprising to me
um maybe it shouldn't have been but in
the Washington Post this morning they
talked about Name ID and we've been
talking about these candidates for a few
months now and I think a lot of our
viewers would be familiar with many of
them but across the board when you have
this many viewers turning in tonight it
really is a chance for them to make a
first impression how what's the best way
to do that you've actually debated in a
contest like this well in Saint ride
race certainly nothing at this level but
there's no question look the elephant in
the room is Donald Trump that's the one
name that everybody knows the fake
ramaswamy I mean he may be known to
certain parts of the country but people
don't know that name they don't even
know in many cases how to pronounce it
uh Chris Christie is someone that people
may remember from four years ago but at
the same time look it's got to be
tonight is a make or break night there
is no clear leader tonight and DeSantis
has lost momentum he's lost momentum I
mean what happened to the guy who won
his race in Florida by 20 points now
he's stiff he's unrelatable he's lost
points and then of course you've got the
vague who I think speaks a populist
message I mean he's run into some
problems but he's never run for office
before but he sounds like he you know he
says things that make a lot of sense and
of course Mike Pence he's got a problem
I mean you've got people who support
Donald Trump and you know Donald Trump
put a sticker on him and Mike Pence
isn't going to be able to wipe that
sticker off his head Chris Christie is
going to be the bully tonight Chris
Kirsty is going to be the guy who's
going to go out there and just beat up
on everybody Jim Scott there's a
sweetheart he's a nice guy he's got
experience in the Senate oh Nikki Haley
I don't understand it this woman has
been hitting the ground on constantly
and I think she was the second to
announce and yet she's only in the
single digits she doesn't seem to be
making it and I agree with Jesse I think
bergam I mean I don't care
I don't care you know but uh look I'm in
excited about tonight I can't wait to
see it
Greg one of the things that we showed at
the beginning was you know there's a
little bit of
Sports going on in this campaign so far
and Vivek was hitting the burpees this
morning with his wife in the garage and
hitting these tennis balls no shirt on
and got good foot movement there yeah
good to see he doesn't wax either I I
find that disturbing I I think it's
clever uh bergam uh is that his name
Brigham yes to use a crutch as a crutch
you know uh and it's also good to see
your candidates in shape people don't
know this I got the job at the five
after beating Greta Van Susteren arm
wrestling so I think it's important but
I do find it a little gratuitous uh
because it defeats the purpose if you're
no if you no longer stand out uh if you
copy somebody else uh then what's the
point and I think that's it kind of
starts to come off as a little thirsty
when everybody does it oh you know it
started with RFK right and he killed it
like he did it first and he looked great
now you know now you have like you know
frantic staffers going do reverse squats
wrestle a bear you know you know do a uh
power walk the mall holding an orphan
but the moment it gets to the public
it's already trite and it's over and
that's why it's a good tip for watching
the debate is to look for the person
that is unlike the others I think we're
past that point of the establishment
politician persuading us I think that
Trump pretty much obliterated that I
don't think you're ever going to kind of
get that thing and then you got the
promise of Joe Biden as an established
politician who like men who came before
lied through his teeth we know that
they're they're shysters so you've got
to find that one person among this
conveyor belt of candidates with the
personality it's like looking at a band
you know it's like the Sex Pistols you
can only name Johnny Rotten you don't
know the others I feel that way with the
debate you only know the names of a few
people and they're the ones the person
out with personality I think Vivek is
probably the Johnny Rotten of that crew
right now and I think that my only other
advice is persuasive beats Applause
lines right you might get you might get
a clap here and there but if you can if
you could actually accurately talk about
the decline in American life and how
you're going to turn around and how your
competitors can't do the same thing
that's better than getting you know a
pop on Twitter or X
or X whatever we're calling it these
days hey judge you would love it here
there's some country music going on
outside I can hear it I don't know if
you can hand it there at home Greg would
be loving this music yes as he should
all right well we're counting down to
the debate at all kicks off at 8 30 p.m
Eastern bill hemmer and I will bring you
the best pre-game coverage you've ever
seen in your life and the big event with
Martha and Brett Bear starts right after
that at 9 00 PM sharp up next President
Biden won't be on the stage himself but
that's not stopping the Democrats from
painting his opponents as extremists I
wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now